So now we've also spent a lot
of time selecting entrepreneurs.
I work with this company in California
that has started schools for
entrepreneurs in a 100 and now I think
160 different countries all over the
world.
This the guy who started this,
whose name is a Dale ressies,
it real,
it's an absolute monster.
The guy started while all he started
all those six schools in five years,
165 schools,
you know in all all across the world,
eight different languages and we've been
screening people for entrepreneurial
ability and if you're going
to be an entrepreneur,
you almost have the opposite profile.
As a soldier,
you're very high in openness and you're
lower in conscientiousness or at least
conscientiousness is irrelevant.
And the reason for that seems to be that
like if you're an orderly person and
you'd like to follow up
procedures and rules,
it's kind of hard for you to start a
company because when you first start a
company or engage in any
other creative process,
because entrepreneurs turned
out to be the same as artists,
you kind of have to,
you're not operating within
a rural governance structure.
In fact,
there may be many times where you
have to break a small rule to,
to move properly at a
higher level of analysis.
There's,
there's no algorithmic way
of generating a new company,
right?
Obviously.
And so it's people who
are very high in openness,
who happened to be good entrepreneurs.
And so they just,
something I thought was
extraordinarily cool because we'd,
we'd also already known what predicts
managerial administrative and academic
ability and Iq is crucial
for any complex jobs.
So we'll just leave that behind.
But what predicts academic ability,
for example at the University of
Toronto is an intelligence obviously,
but also conscientiousness.
The correlation between creativity
and grades at the UFT is zero.
Zero.
Right?
But it's not,
it's not surprising
that the thing is that,
you know,
it's easy to be cynical about that.
But one of the things you
have to understand about
creative people is that they
continually step outside of the
domain of evaluation structures.
Right?
Cause if you're going to say you're going
to evaluate a hundred performance of a
hundred professors on
their lecturing ability,
well you kind of have to measure what's
common across all the professors in
order to come up with the
standards for evaluation.
Well that means you're not going to be
able to use that structure to evaluate a
particularly creative professor because
he or she is going to do something in a
way that's so different that it won't
show up on the evaluation measure.
And of course that's what
happens in universities.
You know,
um,
somebody sent me a couple of days ago,
somebody sent me an essay that they had
written for their master's thesis that
was wildly creative and
they were basically told to
leave the program and that
they couldn't continue.
Not in a mean way.
They,
well,
what happened was that what
they were thinking was,
so outside of the conventions
in the discipline is that
no one had any idea what
to do with the essay.
So,
and then that's really the
law of creative people,
right?
They're always stepping of evaluation
structures and so it's not that surprising
that the relationship between creativity
and grades at the u of t is zero.
We found out as well by
looking at graduate student
performance across multiple
institutions,
that there was a negative correlation
between creativity and graduate school
performance.
It wasn't even zero.
It was worse than negative.
Being creative was negative and you think,
well that could make you cynical as well,
but,
but you can't be cynical in that way
because one of the things that happens in
science is that science tends to progress
incrementally rather than in great
leaps now and then someone comes along
who blows the structure out of a science
advances it ridiculously like Einstein.
But like most people are,
nine Stein had may be thank God for that.
Most of the time you're in a discipline,
you,
you understand the discipline,
and then once you've developed
understanding of the discipline,
you know what the next micro
question is that should be answered.
And part of the reason that science is
so powerful is because it allows people
who aren't genius level creatives to
make real advances in the generation of
knowledge.
One tiny micro step at a time.
It doesn't matter if there's 100,000
people doing it and each of them is making
a micro step.
Man,
we're zipping along as fast as
we possibly want to zip along.
And so it turns out to
be conscientiousness.
That's the excellent predictor
of graduate student performance.
That's the best predictor for law.
It's the best predictor
for managerial positions.
It's the best predictor for
administrative positions.
Anything that has a structure of
rules that needs to be applied,
conscientiousness is a great predictor.
So,
but it's not good for predicting artistic
ability or entrepreneurial ability.
And that's also really important
because one of the things,
this is partly why bureaucracies stultify,
right?
Because what happens is they,
as they develop,
they get chock full of conscientious
people with a few psychopaths thrown in
there just for good measure
that get chocked full of,
of conscientious people busily zooming
efficiently down to single track.
And then all of a sudden the landscape
shifts and they're going very,
very efficiently in exactly
the wrong direction.
And then the whole
bloody thing falls apart.
So you need to have some creative wing
nuts in your organization to come up with
completely absurd ideas that might
just on the off chance be true.
And so creativity is strange in that
manner too because it's a high risk,
high return game.
You're a lot safer in your life to find
a functioning entity and to operate as a
cog within it as long as the
entity keeps functioning.
Because if you're creative and you
go off on tangents all the time,
there's some probability that one of
those tangents is going to be exactly what
is needed at the time and you're
going to become hyper successful as a
consequence.
But there's much more probability
that even though your,
some of your ideas might
be highly valuable,
the probability that this is the
right time and place for them is
extraordinarily low.
So to produce a successful
creative product,
for example,
in the marketplace,
you need a ridiculous combination of
creativity so that you keep generating
ideas and then a network around you of
people who have skills that you don't,
and then the production of a,
of a product,
let's say whatever that happens to be,
that's actually in demand
by the marketplace at
exactly that moment and that
someone else hasn't already done better.
So the sensible thing to tell anybody
who wants to be creative is that stupid.
You shouldn't do it.
It's,
it's your probability of success is so
low that it's better just to do something
sensible.
But the problem with that is that creative
people can't do that because they're
creative and if they shut
down their creativity,
it's like an extrovert
who's gone to live in a,
you know,
in an isolated cell,
a creative person who
isn't being creative,
they just,
they just wither and die.
So they're stuck with it.
So,
but it is a high risk,
high return strategy.
So probably better if you want
to be creative or if you are,
and you should take this advice to heart
because I'd been watching people for a
long time.
If you want to engage
in a creative pursuit,
you should find something stable to do
that will generate you an income and you
should pursue the thing that
you're creative about on the side.
Because monetizing creative production
is so bloody difficult that especially
now like especially in
like artistic domains,
generation of music
and that sort of thing.
It's like you just have no idea how many
million songs there are on the Internet
and the vast majority of the commercially
available get downloaded zero times,
like 80 PR,
I think there's 80 million
songs or something like that
on the net and I believe
it's something in the neighborhood of
70 million get downloaded zero times and
then there's 100 that can get
downloaded like 350 million times.
And so those people are wildly
successful and everyone else collapses in
failure.
Yep.
No,
we'll talk about that more.
Okay.
So that's not a bad overview for,
for initial foray into psychometrics.